well i did say um farouza um i thought
was going to be the favorite if it came
down to this time limit i'm not really
sure why i said that to be honest but
i i honestly think this is just a throw
a coin they're both amazing blitz
players so
it you know it really is 50 50 i think
yeah here we go the blitz has started it
has started and it's the english opening
uh black's bishop coming out now
white just pushing a pawn forward
they'll just get developed they'll get
their pieces out into the center
and transfer the battle to the middle
game very sensible strategy especially
in blitz you don't have to think too
early in the game
you just develop you just kind of
yeah control squares control the center
and what do you guys think about this
choice ferruja if i remember correctly
actually use this opening in the
candidates tournament against ding loren
so for russia sticking to something he
knows magnus of course knows everything
about the openings about all of them
pretty much i think it's a wise choice
by magnus i mean i i think
the english is a good opening but this
is more like you know try to get a small
advantage keep all the pieces on the
board um and just push and here you get
a space advantage this is a quite a nice
structure generally
for white to have but of course black
knows his stuff as well here creating
some problems with that pawn but i don't
know i i i like being white in these
positions uh personally so i'm a bit
biased in white's favor
yeah and i'm not sure in my case this
game still following ding loren against
alariza fruga it still was following and
then i
yes no not anymore okay white pushes the
pawn defending the center but either way
i mean the whether or not ferruja
is following that game he will have
studied the ideas from the black side uh
look at black's clock time as well but
he spent a second for roger up to this
point continues pushing trying to
destabilize white over there on the
queen side that left flank and magnus
will he react i was going to say by
pushing a pawn blocking things up or
more dynamically
getting the white pieces into gear and
simon you like this because white has
more space white has
slightly better development right now in
the center white's knights look pretty
good yeah i mean they they call it it's
a bit like what they call a moroxy bind
set up which is where you get this light
square bishop pointing towards the
middle and uh controlling
the middle with a bit of extra space and
white is also as you as you mentioned a
bit better developed here black's got to
get those queen side pieces into the
game um and i can also see white having
a half open file a weakness that black
has in the middle aboard that pawn being
a problem i mean these are just little
things black's got obviously good pieces
and counter play as well
so still in the balance really early
days as yet yeah definitely early days
and it kind of feels like white has the
slight but slightly better long-term
prospects
and black of course
has a very solid position and active
pieces and i wasn't expecting this move
from uh
magnus
i was expecting the b pawn to push
itself up one square forward
yeah i mean magnus is not scared of uh
basically doing some damage to his pawn
structure here because if black ever
takes
um with his pawn on the side of the
board he's gonna have the better pawn
structure in the long run so all he has
to do is go pawn takes pawn and and
white's pawns are then separated and
they can never connect as we see here so
long term wise actually black has the
better position structurally here's but
piece pieces are all on bags this side
so it's a bit of a double-edged
situation at the moment yeah black
spawn's compromised as well when
ferrugia allowed that trade of knight
for bishop magnus kind of frowned he
grimaced he was like oh that doesn't
look good for you mate
i've seen that face before when i've
made mistakes blunders against magnus it
must be so off-putting you know you play
a move and you get the grimace every
move
is like
but uh either way white's got full
control yeah i mean look at the dark
square bishop i was about to say i mean
this is what you know the grimace white
dark square bishop is just cutting
across the board now
and it looks like a fantastic long-term
piece i mean
yeah
something went wrong there for black
definitely in that little excursion and
he actually has the option of getting
the bishop pair as well um
and uh well ali reza is desperately
going to try to double his rooks along
the a line just to
attack a potentially weak pawn
but is is this kind of enough to offset
everything else that's wrong with his
position
it doesn't look like it looks like the
real action is actually going to happen
towards the black king as simon
mentioned white's dart squad bishop is
the unrivaled minor piece it's pointing
towards that black king sooner or later
white also has that four versus three
pawn advantage on the king side they'll
step towards that black king they'll
create some real problems
and uh
it's nice to keep it kind of in your
pocket capturing that remaining black
bishop with the white knight would see
two bishops against two knights
that imbalance it's unclear who it
favors in general but uh when it's this
open probably the bishop's first magnus
though he wants to play on both flanks
both sides of the board activating his
remaining piece
some threats at some point of that dark
squad bishop jumping out the way and
white's rook hitting some pawns and he's
just being greedy here magnus he wants
the positional advantage and he wants
kind of the dynamic advantage of his
pieces being marketed all right remember
there are two blitz tiebreaks going on
inside the arena duda and prague also
playing and let's quickly hear from
prague's coach ramesh about prague
playing these tie breaks
ramesh coach of pregnant
prague isn't necessarily
as comfortable with the faster time
limits i see
yeah it's
been getting used to this shorter time
control we have been before the lockdown
we are largely focusing on playing
standard time control but
since the loved one we have been
focusing on rapid time controls as well
so it's getting uh with each tournament
is getting better i guess and do you
feel it's good enough to compete in this
format
it's uh
too early to judge uh make a judgment
call on this he's still an upcoming
player he has not yet reached his peak i
believe so only when his reach to speak
probably we should judge whether the
peak is enough or not i still believe he
can grow this extra point is really
important now for the total standings
are you nervous at all as a coach no i'm
not really worried about the standings
as such
to just compete
at this level and the proof is worth
that's what i'm more focusing on rather
than the standings
thank you so much ramesh
and the bar is all the way over to
prague's side with the white pieces in
the first blitz game against young
christophe duda that's why it says that
one point it can turn out to be
very important
two points for a winner and blitz try
breaks one point for the loser the bar
is also over to magnus carlsen's side do
you think he will win this first game
david it's beautiful for white uh
white's rooks look great right now
better than the black rooks which are
staring at a very well protected white
pawn white's minor pieces we've
mentioned the white knight the white
bishops beautiful the white queen now
joining the action
i just don't really see how ferugia is
going to hold this it looks like
tactically as well the black knights are
very poorly placed
i have a feeling that magnus is just
going to rearrange his rooks and move
them away from the left and
maybe place them in the center
and get ready for the
that uh
king side action
yeah exactly magnus can do pretty much
anything he wants right now he does
eventually trade off his knight for
black's bishop so now it is two bishops
against two knights but it's it's clear
the bishops are better pieces both on
their longest possible diagonals
black has those two knights stuck sadly
defending each other especially the
black knight at the top of the board bad
piece better pawn structure for white
everything's in white's favor but we
have seen magnus struggle to convert
advantages in the playoffs against duda
yesterday for example in the blitz clock
time's ticking down as well ferrugia
needs to survive until they both have
around 30 seconds and then it might get
a bit more random
but right now it's just full control for
white
okay
simon
what do you think yeah
looking good yeah just just the same as
same as what you said basically um it's
it's looking great for white i mean
you've even got ideas of bringing the
you know the queen in at some point
you've got everything i mean you've got
the two bishops you've got control of
the open file
and black's knights cannot find any good
squares you've always got to look at
your opponent's pieces see their
potential and if you look at black's
pieces they don't really have any
potential to improve think where those
knights can move to they can't really
they don't have any outposts so um it's
a position which you would have thought
magnus would convert like um over to the
stats person but i'd say 95 of the time
should we say what do you reckon 95
predictions i'd say but um but i think
david mentioned the time is is one of
the only factors i think which could uh
you know go against magnus here he is
down to one minute 20 seconds now so
just smiling meanwhile
is that because the position because
it's so beautiful right now was he still
listening to something a bit
humorous
he must be listening to something but i
mean it doesn't seem to be distracting
him from his play because again he's
doing everything perfectly and the great
thing about this position for magnus is
that there's really no way for ali reza
to kind of mix things up the position is
not that many minor pieces on the board
and there's no way to attack because
yesterday we saw things go wrong when
there was so much activity on the board
and uh magnus just look at that he's
just steam rolling with those pawns on
the right
that's a porn storm incoming yes i mean
the position is very easy to play right
i mean you you literally just well look
at that i mean he even even leaves his
queen on pre uh he's enjoying this a bit
too much i feel at the moment so uh
those pawns are killers and um this is
unnecessary but it's flashy and probably
strong yeah if the if the white queen is
taken by the black knight right now then
the black queen falls and
that only favors white the black queen
looks like she has to run away
maybe she swings herself across the
board or maybe she steps back one square
but that will only give magnus a free
hand to continue the attack no looking
very very good for roger now below on
the clock about to take under one minute
he's a speed monster he can just he can
play 50 moves in a few seconds but in
this position it's just about whether he
survives that far magnus did make big
blunders in the blitz against judah
yesterday is this a different magnus
we're seeing today a lot more sharp
maybe it looks focused
despite the smiles occasionally the one
thing i will say about magnus okay
black's queen getting active there are
some threats now uh but magnus lately in
tie breaks he's not been doing so well
he lost against duda yesterday in the
tie breaks norway chess he lost nearly
every uh tie break i think he lost four
in a row uh four in a row armageddon
matches at some point
um so yeah he's it's not been great for
him not the usual kind of ruthless
nature that we're used to but
here he's just so direct going for
checkmate going for that black king yeah
magnus is in his element in this type of
position
he's just
all his pieces are working and now just
take a look at that pawn on e6 it's just
bulldozing open the black position
yeah i mean the black king is devoid of
any defenders really
and there are tactical issues as well
with black's knight at the top of the
board
it's hanging by a thread does magnus
take back with a pawn here okay i wasn't
sure about this it does allow black's
pawn to move out the way there's some
defense maybe with his rooks on the
seventh rank
i thought he would take with the queen
but i think he take with the queen looks
very straightforward but uh it's still
very strong
or
can do uh kenturo fight back here he's
given a check gives the check the white
king will move to the corner and now
farouza has to i mean the one one thing
is if it does get complicated when
they're both under a minute you
mentioned it this is where farouza might
might have his good chances you know he
might actually
excel over magnus and these quick
complications he doesn't have much time
though played it he's played at the rook
defending now
but uh maybe you can just leave the
queen on this square in some scenarios
not sure whether you want to as magnus
do you want to complicate things but
where does white's queen go
if it retreats the best you can get is a
queen trade so i think matt just has to
give his queen here if he wants to win
this game and i wonder what the top
going on with the time because uh it
does say that fruits clock has run out
i'm pretty sure that is not the case but
um would be popped up on the screen if
it hadn't
would have said okay but he's very short
then they're both getting under 30
seconds we know that now
um but what's he got to play here he's
even got to give up the queen which is
just instinctively risky there we go he
doesn't care he doesn't care he's done
it before and uh farouza seconds left on
the clock getting complicated it's
getting really complicated
this this is messy this is really messy
i mean you can take so many pieces here
just guys at home don't look at the
computer try and calculate this position
for yourself it's it's it's a lot to
calculate uh tonight is coming in if you
allow that black knight to come to f2
and check you you will lose to what we
call smothered mate yeah okay he gets
rid of the knight that was important and
now magnus does give him
wow what a variation and he's got bishop
takes here and it looks like this is the
the key move right the killer move that
black rock in the corner is trapped has
to give itself up for this pawn and now
magnus will simply take this rook it's
two rooks against the queen normally
that's imbalanced but here it's all
about that remaining white pawn yeah and
uh also checkmate will end the game that
knight drops it's two rooks and a bishop
against the queen it's too many material
too many pieces
this one is going to be magnus you can
give a check with his rook here
yeah to pawn he can just move this rook
that's attacked out of the way
the bishop does a great job doesn't it
stopping any checks you know white's
bishop is is a key piece and this is
forcing
uh the win now
yeah magnus makes an e queen he's two
rooks and a bishop up one brook drops
but it won't be enough wise king will
run to safety
got a cross-check here in a lot of
positions we talked about the cross
check earlier
we might see that here black's trying to
check out of trouble but um it's not
going to work no perpetual here yeah the
checks will dry up they'll run out in a
couple of moves time the bishop jumps
back to defend white's king will move
next the white queen will jump back and
defend and
there we go magnus takes the first blitz
game wow he now takes the lead in the
match magnus crawls and frugia in five
minutes blitz game number two he has to
win for joe to take it to an armageddon
tiebreak wow